sorry said I wasn't gonna do this Jesus
that's Don Lemon getting emotional about
his friend and CNN co-worker Chris Cuomo
who was recently diagnosed with a corona
virus he's probably sitting at home
laughing at me the 54 year old news man
was visibly emotional during Tuesday's
broadcast of CNN tonight while talking
with CNN senior global affairs analyst
we hope that this ends soon right we
just don't know how long that'll be
hospitals I'm sorry there was a next
thing sorry I told you I was distracted
yeah sorry about that I also feel for
Chris and and I know it's tough for you
and we're all we're all fighting and
rooting for him tonight
and that's when Don had to reach for the
tissues sorry
see I wasn't gonna do this Jesus he's
probably sitting at home laughing at me
Chris announced on Tuesday that he had
tested positive for kovat 19 noting that
he's quarantined in his basement and he
hopes he didn't give the virus to his
wife Kristina or their children
my brother Chris is positive for
coronavirus found out this morning he is
gonna be fine he's young in good shape
strong not as strong as he thinks
Chris's older brother and the governor
of New York Andrew Cuomo addressed the
news during a press conference I spoke
to him this morning and he's going to be
quarantined in his basement at home he's
just worried about his daughter and his
kids as for Don he explained what those
tears were all about Chris and I are
really good friends we live near each
other
and so when I walk into work every day I
have to walk by where Chris is
so I usually like go to his office and I
say you know and what's doing sometimes
I bring the dogs and we just say hello
anyway he's just not here earlier in the
show Don interviewed Chris via video
chat where's your suit worked on this
heart your black tie in the white shirt
I'm too sick Christina said it didn't
look right for me to be sick in Floreal
suit looks too much like what I might be
buried in
chris is continuing to host his show
cuomo primetime from quarantine and he
had this message for his viewers on
Tuesday night let's use this example of
me having it as proof that you can get
it - god forbid we have to do everything
we can to avoid being sick we have to do
it for ourselves our families and for
those in the front lines who are saving
the lives of people like me and many of
you together as ever as one that is our
remedy what do you say let's get after
it but Don isn't the only reporter to
tear up on-air over the global pandemic
last week Hoda Kotb got emotional on The
Today Show after interviewing NFL Pro
Drew Brees who donated 5 million dollars
to Louisiana coronavirus relief I also
think a lot of things are contagious
including generosity so our hope is is
that because you know you let us know
that you made this big generous donation
I think other people look and say hey
maybe I can help out - drew we love you
love you - ok thank you alright a lot
more later in the show Jota opened up
about her emotional moment with her
co-star Savannah Guthrie who at the time
was reporting from home where she was
self quarantine 8 the other thing too is
you sort of look around for someone to
hug just because and you realize ok yeah
that's that's also part of it but anyway
the new normal we get used to it right
yes and it's not forever yes I'm gonna
be awkwardly hugging you you're gonna be
like get off me Savannah you're a creep
get out of here and I'm not gonna stop
hugging ya